un samedi de juin marquer d'une pierre
blanche dans l'histoire de l'europe tout
à l'heure les chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement vont lancer l'euro
officiellement ils sont arrivés vous le
voyez à bruxelles il ya quelques
instants et vont se retrouver dans un
instant autour d'un déjeuner ce matin ce
sont les députés européens qui ont
avalisé la liste des onze pays candidats
yannick letranchant de conseil en
réunion spéciale de rencontres
informelles en sommet officiel l'europe
à ces procédures l'europe à son
protocole débat ce matin au parlement
sur le passage à la monnaie unique
les élus du peuple européen ont aussi
leur mot à dire je crois que l'euro est
un défi et un risque et donc
mons et à construire la maison
européenne on a renforcé le ceinture
maintenant il faut savoir exactement la
gueule avec le premier anniversaire du
gouvernement blair ce que je ne peux pas
blairer effectivement c'est le manque de
courage du gouvernement britannique qui
n'ont pas pris une décision ils n'ont
pas eu le courage en grand beau talent
et s'il a le grand paradoxe la grande
bretagne a refusé d'entrer dans l'euro
le 1er janvier prochain la grande
bretagne préside ce sommet historique
et c'est son ministre des finances qui
confirmait hier soir la liste des onze
pays qualifiés la france l'allemagne
l'autriche la finlande les pays bas le
luxembourg l'irlande l'espagne le
portugal la belgique et l'italie 11 pays
sur 15 ont décidé d'unir leur destin
monétaire le moment se veut très mouvant
je crois que chacun a conscience de ce
que nous vivons un grand moment de la
création de l'europe elle a commencé
commence pas avec l'euro mais c'est
certainement son arrivée à sa majorité
la majorité ces ultimes étapes
aujourd'hui les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement lanceront officiellement
l'euro et la banque centrale européenne